tomorrow officially kicks off lunar new
year which is typically celebrated with
festivals meals and family reunions
but because of the pandemic those
celebrations are going to look a lot
different this year
reporter kate houston spoke to the owner
of a local chinese restaurant about the
how the pandemic is impacting her
celebrations
yame champion delhi has been serving
authentic chinese and taiwanese dishes
in las vegas for 10 years
over the past decade they've been a
popular spot for families to gather for
lunar new year
it's a big dinner for everybody all the
family
are ready for over 12 dishes
all means good luck owner borman young
says 2019 was the last
full celebration before the pandemic
slowed business and
tourism with that years we have
booked everything from breakfast lunch
and dinner
that all changed when coveted 19 began
to spread in china at the beginning of
2020 which resulted in less
international tourists for chinese new
year
this year instead of a sit-down meal
young will be closing early and
providing traditional new year's treats
for her customers to go
last year we slow a lot like 50
but this year empty zero
the asian chamber of commerce says strip
closures and a lack of conventions
have impacted business owners like yang
tremendously
now many families will be staying home
and celebrating virtually although
it's been a difficult year young says
she hopes the year of the ox will bring
happiness
health and prosperity for the community
i don't care
what's a business or not you stay life
it's the most important stay healthy
it's the most important to help bring in
the lunar new year many resorts and
shops on the strip
as well as downtown summerlin will be
offering unique experiences for locals
and
tourists kate houston 8 news now